the iron stove era at the present era
Nobel Peace Turin if you see it is a
great honor to introduce the Nobel
laureate in physics professor Arthur P
McDonald
your Majesties your Royal Highnesses
excellencies dear laureates students
ladies and gentlemen today I am speaking
for professor Khadija and for our two
scientific collaborations
super-kamiokande and snow of which there
are a number of representatives with us
here today
we would like to express our profound
thanks to your Majesties to the Nobel
foundation and to the Royal Swedish
Academy of Science for this enormous
honor that you have bestowed we are very
grateful for the honor and for the
wonderful hospitality that we have all
enjoyed during our time in Stockholm it
has been said that behind every success
there is effort behind the effort there
is passion behind the passion there are
people with the courage to try professor
cachito and I have been very fortunate
to have many highly skilled and
courageous collaborators and we thank
them for their contributions to our
success
there are several founders of our
collaborations who have passed a way
that we would particularly like to
remember
Yoshi Chuck suka for super-kamiokande
and herb chen for snow we will be
forever thankful for their contributions
to the success of our experiments I'm
also very glad that another of our
founding spokespersons for snow
professor George Yuen is here to
celebrate with us today we would also
like to express our thanks and love to
our spouses and families and to those of
our collaborators who have been so
supportive of our work over many years
the Reiter very appreciative of the
tremendous support we've received from
our international funding partners as
well as from the mining companies in
Japan and Canada and from atomic energy
of Canada through the loan of heavy
water for snow our experiments have
exhibited properties for neutrinos that
were unknown before including flavor
change and a finite mass we're very
pleased
changed the perspective on neutrinos in
the most fundamental theories of physics
and look forward to future experiments
that can lead to a the way to a more
complete understanding of those theories
and of our universe as a whole
thank you sincerely for this great honor